então quando diovan sim sim eu estou aqui com
minha boa amiga Gabrielle que é uma
incrível poliglota errante que viaja
pelo mundo e eu vi muitos de seus
vídeos onde ele fala de um
número notável de línguas eu nunca vi você
falar  para um tipo de cara
velho como você sabe que geralmente você fala com
garotas, mas de qualquer maneira, deixe-me ter um jogo,
Gabrielle, explicando o canal dele, porque
acho que hoje chegamos a cem
mil inscritos com ciúmes na semana
passada, finalmente chegamos, então talvez você  poderia
dizer aos meus espectadores um pouco sobre
você
soa bem então basicamente meu nome é
Gabriel Silva ele nasceu e foi criado no
Brasil eu levei muito tempo para aprender
inglês e então eu pensei que costumava ser
péssimo em idiomas e por causa disso eu
comecei  me dedicando a aprender
idiomas para ver se eu poderia melhorar então
me tornei fluente em alguns continuei
desenvolvi um grande interesse por aprender
idiomas e agora basicamente ensino
inglês e tenho muitos cursos
qual é o na  eu do seu canal pegue o
português um é Gabriele poliglota ah
Gabriele poliglota um eleitor doozy em
português claro ok então Gabrielle a
mamãe amigo mio amico keyfob muchos
linguista taehoon canal e YouTube super
parênteses e inglês Singh ele deveria
remar na estrela falando kun city  cancele
este radhika wrappers conheça todas as cores
sem nós suba e não suba como
luminescentes nos deixa com os
fabricantes de beijos mars oj vamos falar
sobre problemas comunista e inglês
provavelmente foi kiss on venha para agente
de língua português em inglês em uma
língua japonesa  sobre problemas que sempre
oh whoa não eu ouço o
sotto da escola também Aussie Aussie
como se diz tamuka tempo can on fala
portugues in town você está tão calmo oh
não é um clima sombrio dia importante um
poderoso se allah pai e
então lá como  a cujos são uma lingua um
civil diga sem dor um cenário civil prado
pode forçar uma nota um cometa e flechas
verso a non cava progresso agora são lingua
no Alvo Farr  akhan flechas mas não fez
tango importante senhor ok
qualquer inglês sempre
l4v nenhum gigante não é pessoas conforme fonte KD
dizendo sou interessante sou interessante
no filme sou sou chata sou
chata na aula sou empolgante
sabe ASA não  de jeito nenhum correcto é
muy muy importante perseverar a
diferencia entry entediado e chato então
os vídeos do Steve são chatos eu não acho
que esses vídeos são chatos mas a
pessoa que está ouvindo meu vídeo está entediada
ok eu estou animado para assistir o filme não
eu  sou o filme pode ser excitante sim
o filme pode ser excitante normalmente não se
diz que estou excitando o mesmo
com interesse
estou interessado em algo não fiz um
vídeo em inglês não sentado nenhum efeito sobre o
destino no vídeo em inglês sobre su
problema a Ashoke quero dizer seu curso a
para meteora ver vas uma primeira fase
é um erro cometido uma mera causa eu sei
um não José Padilla herdeiras de Picasso
e liberal a gramatical pero es ANOVA
eu fiz nosso Muto franca significou em substituir o
que'  sa tank a scooter muchas gracias
muchas veces está tudo bem
rápido simplesmente por exemplo como
mini-armazenamento que temos e no link cotovelo
scooter foi turismo lave os
quantizes para criar Novus Abydos da Nova
você conhece Nell cerebro em melissa é
internalizado eu conheço um humanista  possuía um
comprender Reza Reza
porque por caning menos mãe não sno-isle
judô Muay Tom Lenk ei scooter scooter uma
camada uma scooter há um manera um poco
um poco saba mayara
no Ziggy eles não são tão bons sr.  Guido
e sikita você tem os pólos os meninos não,
mas ainda Ozzy Osbourne continua nosso hey
vamos lá vamos lá
obrigado continue nosso AC foi uma nota no
Colorado Muto ele corre time templo define
tempo não para ver se uma larva me segue
amanhã como agora  english venha com
um pouco disso pero sim muy importante
porque si era um manso a compreender então hey
uma compreensão haces que si era a
bolita eles seguem
Seba peor e Jose Vasquez Ando pero eu
compreendo então não sou otra Rizal Park
aa muy importante
para  carro dizer que ele disse sem concentração na
entrada scooter la paura permitir ouvido oh
desculpe mano
os cray-cray são criados criar
romances um hábito de ábaco ábaco ok
alcance planar Yoshiki barato ou sádico
não importa ok também diga algumas
coisas em português ok  então eu acho que
depois do solo recente ok você realmente
move a lua para o potencial significa que ela colocou
uma exposição no nosso trabalho, mas eu estava dizendo que os do
Canadá são o mm-hmm do SSKIN Saito cujo
verbo o tensiona para acabar com a coca-cola
porco  se você vir agora na compra de acessórios
ele é Flicka jean-pierre sim, por
exemplo cantor animado empolgante mas o
compromisso foi então o VG dirá que os
samples de Oh Vera são de dez polegadas como stevia splick
Oh animado Estou animado para ver o filme que
o filme foi  emocionante isso é um
filme emocionante ele você sabe que algo é
chato e eu estou entediado como resultado, mas minha
Sylvie era a mesma mais eu amo Sarah
diz que era um menino sim Mira ou humor do vídeo
são gasosos você um vídeo vídeo nós damos
um  vídeo importe nosso vídeo sem link cante na
excursão pela cidade Nestlé menos som ouça
me conhecendo então ouça Marissa
sim eu você o Muto uma mesa a estes são
menores opus um download de quatro dias sem
download legal Relatório do Safari contra kisi
pode baixar por tiro
como fazer é  uma scooter ou áudio
cantando está tudo bem FSO todos dias cuando esto em
pé e o árabe uma língua côncava mesmo
presto scoot andando muito mais
falando D tempos os tempos não ok eu sou
problema entose link was no temperature
é oficialmente em inglês feito batendo um
bastan  te derrotado se fosse uma licença
o molho o
que é uma coisa Nolan por exemplo agradecer a um
salwar servidor seguro sóbrio
frases sem musica palabras meu Francey alegre
simplesmente coisa
ultra indica soja da da tempo por exemplo
eu sempre como era um pedido de desculpas eu sempre
estou sempre comendo  sem assistente eu sempre
como bem
por exemplo eu estava comendo
quando Gabriel ligou ok então quando Emma
autre palabra uma indica costura doe
tempo
et vous diga um link por exemplo de um
bashar al-assad VAR s as francis is too
dark SS processo chamado do Naaman  era
nominee remise constante em vez de s7 s
de uma permissão ouvido cerebro o traje RC
é uma esta manera de fallar K distinto
hoje de manera um membro para olhar
por que cada yama 10 centavos soozluecke
turistas 10 é manera isso o
expresso nossas causas CFS  fotos não satis
scheppers testes de superfície nos definir
professor
ok em la la profesora mas nosso
orador Mutasa logo ver massa é uma entrada decente pobre
Santi parable diga oh não chato
antes disso não ayuda muita a ratos ratos
camundongos beneficiados ou não meu cbenni
benéfico foi sobre minha emma
cormier muitos são butão Ilia
veja bem qual é a pressa desistir de
licor muito abaixo dessa coisa toda pobre
conversa depreciada do oceano é um
brilhante próprio lucro de projetos
separados de satanás eu me afundo  cantor
dirá quem é chato a primeira música da nasa
use um ninho de pássaro ou filho meu filho consegue
uma resistência provisória uma escola falando
placa chata versus elaborada diga David
Cicilline lábios um pai pode acontecer
perto da intervenção diga em dizer ao
eterno é uma música sim tudo bem eu  ll
basicamente para mim brunch Brasil para a
serie como se ai ta ok agora posso
apresentar mood ok vovô
Italo
você